We chose a random gas station in Finland
and gave drivers
a full tank of free gas
If they could receive
a pro table tennis serve!
Watch until the end
to see how many could do it!
Three tries
How many liters do
you think it's gonna go?
50!
Well, that's like 100€
A price worth competing for!
Yeah.
Ooh, second one.
Ah!
Still a bit too much here.
It was really curved!
Whoa, wow!
The wind is...
I don't know if it's on our side
or the people's side?
Ooh! It's not making things easier.
That's for sure.
Good try!
Have you played table tennis before?
Sometimes!
OK. So the last serve
will be with a chocolate racket
In honor of the 5 million subscribers challenge!
Which means building the world's
biggest chocolate rocket
and actually playing with it.
If we hit 5 million
by the end of the year.
Make sure you
subscribe to see this happen!
Ooh, that was close!
Thanks!
Thanks for the challenge.
Yeah, let's go!
The truck actually stopped!
Just for one table tennis ball!
Oh man!
This guy knows how to play!
They have a cheering group over there!
Any final words?
It was a very good effort
Go stream my music!
"Santerivaa"
So I don't have to sell
gutters for my whole life!
Can we hear a small sample of your music?
Pongfinity
Shout out to these guys!
Let's go!
🎵Tää vaatii tunteja, useita toistoja🎵
🎵Ja vaalii euroja, upeita muistoja🎵
🎵Tää tarvii tarpeeks vauhtii🎵
🎵...🎵
NICE!!
Go and check it out!
So this was Finnish water construction team
No success this time
But good efforts!
*Laughter*
Our opponent gets to choose
whoever of us
serves to her!
Who looks like they have the easiest serve?
Okay...
No offense Emil!
You hit it!
That's good.
Ace!
Alright!
Ooh!
Could I get a wind discount on that one?
Oooohh!!
He got it!!
Did you see the curve!
Well done!!
Nice!
The arc was like beautiful
The wind was coming
Regards to Kliffa!
So: Hey to Kliffa!
All right, go for it!
So the tank is almost empty
So he gets full benefit of this challenge!
Just under 100 Euros
It's big money for me!
For everybody yeah!
My Monday is a happy day!
Awesome! That's good to hear.
Thank you guys!
First person to receive the serve!
He was a happy guy.
He said his Monday is a happy Monday now.
That's always nice to hear!
Yeah, that's nice!
I see a car coming!
So the next challenger
Do you...?
Free gas?
Yeah.. no!
Next!
Is there a challenge here?
No Emil! Get out!
We need more challengers!
You up for the challenge?
Yes, of course!
That's great!
I have my own table at home!
Good try!
That was a good try.
He's coming in with force!
Last chance!
That was so close!
This close!
All right. Thanks.
Thanks.
There's mental support!
Calculating the spin
I'm trying, yeah!
Oooh, good tries!
Oh, they have an electric car!
We will pay the electricity.
And if you don't get the serve on
You have to give us Red Bull?
Lassi you should be the one serving!
Ok Lassi!
We trust you.
We want some Red Bull.
So if you win, we get nothing?
I don't know...?
Lassi!
Can we have one each for sympathy?
Of course you can!
Normal or zero?
The zero one!
because that's how I feel about myself.
Okay
Do you still wanna try
some of our serves?
Almost!
Oooh!
They got it!
Oh, there's this military guy.
Should we ask them?
Today's main exercise!
Over!
Under!
Oooh almost with the finger!
Good try!
Backhand smash!
Oh, pen hold!
Good tries though!
Oooooh!!
That was it!
Nice one, good job!
Oh lefty!
- Let's go!
Lefties are really good at receiving serves!
There was some spin on that ball!
And that ball is lost forever!
Noooo!!
He ran over the ball!
We have now tested the Pongfinity balls...
They cannot handle a truck
which is surprising...
Thank you.
So to spice things up
we're going to move on to bigger tanks!
Do you speak English?
No English. Polish!
How big is the tank?
600 liters.
You want to do the serve challenge?
Nawww!
That's good for us!
So let's find our next victim
from the regular car section!
She's scared
She's up for the challenge!
She's thrilled to join us.
Ok, are you ready for the challenge?
Oh, yes.
Here's the racket.
Have you played table tennis before?
Yes.
Ooohhhh she got it first try!!
And there's no reaction!
Congrats!
That's amazing!
Thanks!
I think that's the first person ever
to return the first serve!
Filling up Milja's car.
40 liters of free gas!
Thank you!
You saw the beard?
I'm a bit envious!
I think you have to do the serve
So we have the battle of the beards!
Go easy on me!
Last one
Thank you!
So the last one
With a chocolate racket
Like that!
46 liters and 101 Euros!
Always try!
Even if not knowing how to!
Wise words!
You always have to try,
even though you don't know how to.